foreign
hi everyone this is Professor mdos
science and today I want to build the
eigenvalues and eigenfunctions of the 3D
isotropic Quantum harmonic oscillator in
another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics if you've been
following us for a while you will
probably know that we have already
calculated the energy eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of the 3D isotropic
oscillator in these videos we found that
the energy eigenvalues of the 3D
isotropic oscillator are quantized and
that we can write the energy
eigenfunctions as the product of three
1D oscillator energy eigenfunctions so
you may wonder why would we want to do
this again well today we're going to
study the 3D harmonic oscillator with a
different approach we're going to treat
it as a central potential as expected we
will find that the energy eigenvalues
are exactly the same as the ones that we
found in the other videos but the energy
the eigenfunctions are going to look
very different today we're going to
write them so that they're also
eigenfunctions of orbital angular
momentum which means that they will be
given in terms of spherical harmonics so
a quick disclaimer what we're going to
do today has to build on the rather long
mathematical solution of the eigenvalue
equation of the 3D oscillator as a
central potential so I would encourage
you to check out the corresponding video
if you haven't done it yet so let's go
okay so what do we know about the
three-dimensional isotropic Quantum
harmonic oscillator
working in the position representation
the corresponding hamiltonian H has a
kinetic energy term
and the potential energy term has a
quadratic form which in 3D can be
separated into a term proportional to x
squared a term proportional to y squared
and the term proportional to Z squared
we are interested in an isotropic
oscillator and this means that the
frequencies are the same along each
Cartesian Direction and we call them
simply Omega
we can then rewrite the hamiltonian with
the same kinetic energy and for the
potential energy we can take this common
factor multiplied by this sum of squares
and using spherical coordinates this is
simply the square of the distance R from
the origin and this means that the
hamiltonian of a three-dimensional
isotropic Quantum harmonic oscillator
has the usual kinetic energy term and a
potential energy term that is equal to
one-half M Omega squared r squared
the dependence in R means that the
three-dimensional isotropic Quantum
harmonic oscillator is described by a
central potential
so the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian is given by H acting on the
eigenfunction and equal to the eigen
energy times the eigen function and as
always we're interested in finding these
eigenvalues and these eigen functions
the mathematical solution of this
eigenvalue equation is rather involved
but it's also interesting for example it
involves a power series expansion so for
the full mathematical details we have a
companion video where we go over the
solution step by step I really do
recommend that you watch it now if you
haven't done it yet because today we
will start from there to build a few
examples of the eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions and explore some of their
properties
one important feature of the
eigenfunctions is that they can be
chosen to also be eigenfunctions of the
L squared orbital angular momentum
operator like this where remember that
the quantum number L can take any
non-negative integer value
and the eigenfunctions can be chosen to
also be eigenfunctions of the LZ orbital
angular momentum operator like this
where for a given L the quantum number
ml can only take one of the values
between minus L and L in steps of one
with this knowledge we can rewrite the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
where we label the eigenfunctions and
eigenvalues with the appropriate quantum
numbers like this
we see that the eigenfunctions depend on
the orbital angular momentum of quantum
numbers L and ml and for every
combination LML we have a spectrum of
energy eigenfunctions labeled by the
additional quantum number okay
now in principle the energy eigenvalues
can also be labeled by these three
quantum numbers but we find in the
videos on Central potentials that they
actually only depend on K and L but not
on ML
an important side note there's a link in
the description to a video where we've
already solved the 3D isotropic Quantum
harmonic oscillator but we take a
different route using Cartesian
coordinates and tensor product State
spaces
in that case the energy eigenfunctions
are not eigenfunctions of orbitaling the
momentum so they take a different form
to the form that we are going to explore
today
so as an interesting exercise I would
really encourage you to go and compare
both sets of eigenfunctions
right so let's start with a quick
refresher based on the companion video
where we solve this eigenvalue problem
mathematically
remember that the full eigenfunction PSI
is given by the product of a radial part
and an angular part
this angular part here is the same for
any Central potential and is given by
the spherical harmonics which are the
orbital angular momentum eigenfunctions
and only depend on the quantum numbers L
and ml
the radial part here depends on the
precise form of the radial potential and
is labeled by the quantum numbers k and
l
what we do in the companion mathematical
video is to figure out this radial part
of the eigenfunction and doing so takes
a rather large number of steps
first we Define a new function U which
is related to the original radial
function by this equation
then considering the limit of large R we
Define another function V which is
related to the U function via this
relation
and then we express the function V in a
power series like this in terms of
expansion coefficients C
and the lowest power s in the expansion
is equal to l Plus 1.
finally the expansion coefficients C
obey a recurrence relation between C Q
Plus 2 and CQ
equal to this pre-factor times this long
numerator
divided by this long denominator
we also have that the first non-zero
expansion coefficient is c0 while C1
vanishes
and all other expansion coefficients can
be constructed from these two using the
recurrence relation and in particular as
C1 vanishes we can immediately conclude
that all odd expansion coefficients must
also vanish
for the even expansion coefficients we
will always be able to write them in
terms of c0
so we can then complete the solution
fixing c0 by normalization of the wave
function
and that's it this is the strategy that
we will follow in this video to build
the eigenfunctions
first we will determine what the CE
expansion coefficients are and then from
those we can construct V once we have V
we can construct U once we have U we can
construct the radial function and once
we have R we can finally build the
complete eigenfunctions
with this recipe we can build any
eigenfunction that we want and in this
video we look at a few examples of how
to explicitly do this step by step
so as we just discussed we need to
normalize the wave function to fix the
c0 coefficient the full wave function to
base the standard normalization
condition so we could fix c0 by imposing
that condition
however in the videos on Central
potentials we discussed that we can
separately normalize the radial part of
the eigenfunction
and the angular part of the
eigenfunction
indeed we have already built the
spherical harmonics such that they
themselves are normalized so in
principle we can fix c0 by using this
normalization condition for the radial
part of the eigenfunction
but in the video on the radial equation
we found that we can equivalently
normalize the U function using this
relation
the original normalization of the radio
function involves the r squared here
but the normalization in terms of the U
function does not so this expression is
in general simpler so today we will
normalize the wave function and fix c0
using this U integral
before we start building eigenfunctions
we also need to discuss eigenvalues
again drawing from the results in the
companion video
the eigenvalues are in principle labeled
by the indices K and L and given by this
expression
however we can see that K and L only
appear together as a sum here so we can
define a new Collective label n and then
the eigenvalues can be labeled by this
single label e n and are given by H bar
Omega times n plus 3 over 2.
on top of that we know that the angular
momentum quantum number L can take
non-negative integer values
and we also found in the companion video
that K can only take non-negative even
values
so from these we can conclude that n can
take any non-negative integer value
we can actually say more starting from
the fact that n is equal to K plus l
let's start with n equals zero
this will be the ground state and the
only possible values are k equals 0 and
L equals zero
for the fast excited state n equals one
as K can only be even and non-negative
then it must still be zero and this
means that L must be one in this case
for n equals 2 we now have that K can be
zero in which case L must be 2 or k can
be two and then L must be zero and we
could continue in this fashion for any n
okay we're now ready in the rest of the
video we are going to look at a few
examples of the eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions of the 3D isotropic
Quantum harmonic oscillator
let's start with the eigenvalues and
let's first consider the ground state n
equals zero
if we look at the expression for the
energy up here the ground state energy
is equal to three halves H bar Omega
and I would now encourage you to compare
this with the ground state energy that
we got in the video where we solve this
problem using Cartesian coordinates
and you will be able to confirm that
surprise surprise we got exactly the
same energy
sticking with the ground state let's now
turn to the eigenfunctions the first
thing to remember is that for n equals
zero we've just established that K is
zero and that L is also zero
to build the eigenfunctions we now have
a rather large number of steps and the
first one is to determine the expansion
coefficients using the recurrence
relation up here
first remember that we can write the
even expansion coefficients in terms of
c0 and we can start with the first one
corresponding to Q equals zero
inserting this value of Q inside the
equation at the top we get C2 in terms
of C zero we now insert these values of
N and L into the recurrence relation and
replacing all Q's else and ends by zeros
we get this very long expression
these two terms add up to three halves H
bar Omega and we've just found that the
ground state energy up here is also
three-halves H bar Omega
this means that we can cancel this term
with this term and this expression
vanishes
this means that C2 is equal to zero
given the recurrence relation once we
have a Vanishing even expansion
coefficient all higher order even
expansion coefficients also vanish
remember also that all expansion
coefficients vanish for odd Q
putting these results together we have
that all expansion coefficients CQ are
zero for any positive Q
in other words the only non-zero
expansion coefficient for the ground
state is indeed C 0.
the next step is to build a V for which
we use this expression as K and Del are
zero for the ground state we label V
with the sub indices 0 0.
next as we've just established that all
expansion coefficients are zero apart
from the first one that corresponds to Q
equals zero then this sum has a single
term which leads to this expression
finally as s is equal to l plus one but
L is zero then the power of R is simply
one
and this means that we get that V 0 0 is
equal to c0 times r
okay the next step is to build you from
V using this relation
inserting the expression we got for v00
into this equation we get U 0 0 as equal
to c0 times R times the gaussian
at this point we have to normalize the
wave function to fix c0 and we've argued
that to do so we will use the
normalization condition on the U
function as shown up here
for writing it for arcades we get this
and we can now use this expression for U
0 0 up here and we end up with this new
integral
we're now going to use a standard
gaussian integral which you can look up
in your favorite table of integrals and
which is equal to this
now if we compare this exponent with our
exponent up here we can identify a as
equal to the square root of H bar over M
Omega
with this we can evaluate the integral
to get the absolute value squared of c0
multiplied by this constant
isolating c0 we get that it's equal to
this expression where I have made some
trivial rearrangements note that I have
also made a phase Choice such that we
end up with a real positive constant
with this result we can rewrite u0 as
equal to the prefactor times R times the
gaussian
and we're almost there the next step is
to go to the original radial function
which is equal to 1 over R times U
and using the expression for you that we
just arrived and inserting it in here we
can write the radial function R zero
zero and end up with this prefactor
times this gaussian
finally the full eigenth function is
given by the product of the radial
function and the corresponding spherical
harmonic as shown up here
in our case at L equals zero then ml
only has one possible value which is
also zero
using the results for the video on
spherical harmonics y 0 0 is equal to 1
over the square root of 4 pi
we can next insert this expression for
the spherical harmonic all the way up
here
and this expression we just found for
the radial function into this term and
we end up with the ground state wave
function of the three-dimensional
isotropic Quantum harmonicles later
being equal to this pre-factor times
this gaussian term
the ground state is non-degenerate so
this eigenfunction is unique
and indeed if you compare this with the
ground state that we got in the other
video where we solve this problem in
Cartesian coordinates then you will be
able to confirm that we got the exact
same eigenfunction
moving on it is great to have the
mathematical expression for these
eigenfunctions like the graph State here
but we also want to visualize them
unfortunately we cannot fully visualize
them because they depend on three
coordinates which means that we would
need a four-dimensional space to plot
them so what we will do instead is to
separately visualize the radial part and
the angular part
this is a depiction of the ground state
eigenfunction
the radial part on the left here is
purely real and shows that the
eigenfunction decreases in magnitude as
we move away from the origin of the
central potential
specifically its shape is described by a
gaussian function
moving to the angular part on the right
right here it is an eigenstate of
orbital angular momentum and in this
particular case it is the y00 spherical
harmonic which is simply a constant
if you need a refresher of how to plot
spherical harmonics by the way we have a
video that does does that and we've
linked it in the description but briefly
as they only depend on angular variables
we plot them on the unit sphere and use
a red white blue color gradient scale
with red being positive white represents
zero and blue corresponds to negative
values in this case we get a uniform red
sphere because the Y 0 0 spherical
harmonic is a positive constant
and overall the ground state
eigenfunction takes its maximum value at
the origin of the central potential and
then decays away from the origin and it
does so isotropically
let's now turn to the fast excited stage
and as the procedure is analogous to
what we just did for the ground state we
will move quicker through the
calculations but I do encourage you to
fill in the gaps and to make sure that
you understand every step that we take
let's again start with the eigenvalues
and we now consider n equals one
the energy E1 is equal to five halves H
bar Omega again I encourage you to
compare this result with the
corresponding one in the video where we
treat this problem using Cartesian
coordinates and you should find that
they are identical
let's now turn to the eigenfunctions the
first question is how can we get n
equals one as a combination of K and Del
we've just established that this rises
from having k equals 0 and L equals one
we next consider the first time of the
recurrence relation which is given by Q
equals zero
this term gives us C2 in terms of C 0.
and using the values of ql and N that we
have we get this very long expression
these two terms add up to five halves H
bar Omega and the first excited state
energy up here is also five halves H bar
Omega so we can cancel this term with
this term and this means that C2 is
equal to zero again
so for the first excited stage the power
series again has all expansion
coefficients CQ equal to zero for any
positive Q this means that again the
only non-zero expansion coefficient for
the first excited state is indeed c0
the next step is to build V using this
expression we have that V 0 1 has a
single term
as s is equal to l plus 1 and now we
have that L is equal to one then the
power of R is 2. and this means that we
get that v01 is equals to c0 times r
squared
the next step is to build U from V using
this relation
and we get that u01 is equal to C 0
times r squared times the gaussian
we again determine C 0 by normalizing
the function U
inserting the expression we have for U
into the normalization integral we get
this expression
we can again evaluate this expression
using a standard gaussian integral and
skipping a few manipulations we get this
now rearranging we get that c0 is equal
to this expression where I have again
made a phase Choice such that we end up
with a real positive constant
with this result we can rewrite U 0 1 as
equal to this pre Factor
times r squared times the gaussian
going to the original radial we end up
with this pre-factor times R times this
gaussian
finally the full eigenfunction is given
by the product of the radial equation
and the corresponding spherical harmonic
as shown up here
in this case as L equals one then ml has
three possible values
using the results from the video on
spherical harmonics we have that y 1
minus 1 is equal to this expression
y 1 0 is equal to this expression
and Y 1 1 is equal to this other
expression
this leads to three distinct
eigenfunctions for the first excited
state the first one is PSI 0 1 minus 1
and is given by this combined prefactor
the r dependent terms and the angular
dependent terms
the second one is PSI 0 1 0 and is given
by this combined prefactor the r
dependent terms and again the angular
term
and the third is psi011 which is given
by this other combined prefactor they
are dependent terms and the angular
terms
we therefore have a triply degenerate
first excited state for the
three-dimensional isotropic Quantum
harmonic oscillator
now this is an interesting bit as the
first excited state corresponds to a
degenerate energy eigenvalue then the
corresponding energy eigenfunctions are
not uniquely defined
indeed if you compare these three energy
eigenfunctions to the corresponding ones
we find in the video where we solve the
3D harmonicles later using Cartesian
coordinates you will find that lo and
behold they are actually different
in particular in today's video we've
chosen the energy eigenfunctions to also
be eigenfunctions of the orbital angular
momentum which leads to these
expressions in terms of spherical
harmonics
by contrast in the other video where we
solved this problem using Cartesian
coordinates we don't really use orbital
angular momentum eigen functions and as
a result they look different
however we do know that we can always
make linear combinations of
eigenfunctions corresponding to a
degenerate eigenvalue to obtain equally
valid eigenfunctions and you should now
go and try this out and try and relate
today's results with those that we got
in the video where we used Cartesian
coordinates
right let's finally draw the first
excited state wave functions
here I'm showing the radial part which
is the same in all three eigenfunctions
it vanishes at the origin here it has a
maximum at some fine distance from the
origin right here
and then it decreases in size as we move
away from the origin of the central
potential
the angular parts are different and are
given by the corresponding spherical
harmonics
this here shows the radial part we've
just discussed together with the Y one
minus one spherical harmonic
to help with the visualization we can
make the diagram of the spherical
harmonic rotate like this
and the Y one minus one spherical
harmonic is a complex function and we're
plotting both it's real and its
imaginary parts
and again if you need a refresher about
how exactly we plot the spherical
harmonics you can check out the
corresponding video that we've Linked In
the description
this here shows the radial part together
with the y10 spherical harmonic in this
case the spherical harmonic is a real
function that is spherically symmetric
and this here shows the radial part
together with the y11 spherical harmonic
which we can make rotate and which has
both real and imaginary components
we could repeat the same exercise for
higher excited States but now that
you've seen how it works for the first
few you will be able to calculate the
eigenfunctions for any other state
yourself
to encourage you to explore this further
I will finish the video by showing the
results for the second excited state
that corresponds to n equals 2.
the energy of the second excised state
is equal to seven halves H bar Omega
we've seen earlier in the video that
there are two possible choices of K and
L that give this value a friend
the first possibility is k equals 0 and
L equals two from this value of L we get
these five possible values for ML
overall this means that we will end up
with five eigenfunctions
four ml minus two
we get PSI 0 2 minus two
for ml equals minus one we get PSI 0 2
minus one
4 ml zero we get PSI 0 to 0
for ml equals one we get PSI zero two
one
and for ml equals two we get PSI 0 2 2.
but we can also get n equals two with k
equals two and L equals zero in that
case ml equals zero so the second case
leads to a single eigenfunction which is
PSI two zero zero
overall what we see here is that the
second excited state is six-fold
degenerate
here I'm showing you a plot of the radio
functions associated with fat second
excited state
the figure on the left corresponds to
the case when k equals 0 and L equals
two
in this case the series solution again
has a single non-zero term corresponding
to the C 0 expansion coefficient
the radial function vanishes at the
origin here it has a maximum at some
finite distance from the origin here and
then decreases in size as we move away
from the origin of the central potential
this radio function is shared between
five distinct eigenfunctions whose
angular part is given by the L equals
two spherical harmonics
the figure on the right shows the radial
function when k equals 2 and L equals
zero in that case the series expansion
has two non-zero expansion coefficients
C 0 and C2 the resulting radial function
is positive at the origin right here it
then becomes negative Beyond this point
and it approaches zero again as we move
away from the origin this radial
function is associated with a single
eigenfunction whose angular part is
given by v l equals zero spherical
harmonic
when we treat the 3D isotropic Quantum
harmonic oscillator as a central
potential its energy eigenfunctions are
also eigenfunctions of orbital angular
momentum now as a fun follow-up I would
encourage you to compare the results
that we got today to those that you get
if you treat the 3D oscillator as the
tensor product over three 1D oscillators
and you're going to see that the energy
eigenfunctions take a rather different
form and as always if you liked the
video please subscribe
foreign